if you close your eyes
yes
and a hundred years ago 1922 and you
think about the future
i wonder if you can hear the drums of
war
predicting the 30s predicting
the great depression and the resentment
that builds
the economic resentment the cultural
resentment the geopolitical resentment
that builds and leads to world war ii
it uh at least to me when i close my
eyes i can hear the drums of war that
are still
ahead of us
and it's possible that
where
their
2022
will materialize in a similar way as the
1922.
i have my eyes closed lex do you hear
anything and i sure hope that that's not
what happens
but i'm looking in 1922 it's an epoch i
know well
and i don't see the future that unfolds
i would not have predicted it had i been
alive then
i see the war behind us
i see
uh prosperity on the horizon yes
inflation in germany and
and some many other
uh difficult issues but there are
more democracies now than there were
before the war and the old empires are
gone
and there's a cultural efflorescence and
there's modernism in the arts and
and there's women entering the public
sphere and there's all this fantastic
new technology like automobiles and
i'm looking at the future from 1922 and
and i'm not seeing the great depression
and i'm not seeing world war ii and i'm
not seeing the holocaust
because
i don't predict the future and nobody in
1922 could see that future although
i guess there were some clairvoyance who
predicted it but
but you're not one of them yeah i'm not
one of them and and
but but this is what i know lex from
studying history
what i know is stuff happens
in other words very deep insight in
other words like
we're watching ukraine war right now
and all of our attention is focused on
that
and it's like the economists say in
their textbooks when their their
powerful models
are employed
and there's this line that says
all
other factors held constant comma
and then the model works
and you get this really great result
it's very powerful predictor and
analysis the model
and the whole game is all other factors
held constant
so the russia ukraine war that we've
been discussing and this could happen
and that could happen
but you know what stuff could happen
likes
for example
the israeli government could decide this
summer that it's going to bomb iran
because no israeli government will
tolerate iran acquiring a nuclear weapon
and since president trump
exited unilaterally exited from the
multi-power nuclear agreement
iran is now much closer to the bomb than
they were
when they were still in when the united
states was still in that agreement
and you tell me the israeli government
that says sure it's fine it's okay iran
can get the bomb
and so maybe that happens and maybe that
happens as early as this summer as iran
gets closer and closer and closer
maybe
that
guy in north korea decides it's his time
just like his grandfather
right in 1950
decided you know it's time we're going
to quote reunify unquote the korean
peninsula
maybe
i don't know lex fill in the blank
something's going to happen it's not
going to be what i predict it's not
going to be what i'm watching
it's going to be obvious only after it
happens not before
and then it's gonna upend the table
and all of a sudden
everything changes we're gonna be in a
different environment different
circumstances and is ukraine still
as central at that point as it seems to
be right now i don't know the answer to
that question
you